-Qui est pour ?
Qui est contre ?
-La séance est levée.
Générique
...
-Bruno Millienne, député de la 9e
circonscription des Yvelines.
Avec Gérard Leseul,
nous avons fait un rapport
sur les ZFE,
les zones à faibles émissions
de mobilité,
avec tous les freins
à la mise en place de ces ZFE
et toutes les contraintes
que cela suppose
pour les particuliers
et les professionnels.
Mon boulot, maintenant,
c'est d'expliquer ça
à nos administrés,
à nos concitoyens
et leur dire qu'on a
des solutions alternatives
à mettre en place.
C'est une question
de santé publique.
-Le sujet est brûlant,
voire explosif.
Il va toucher
des millions de Français.
A peine installées,
les ZFE suscitent
colères et inquiétudes.
Les ZFE, ce sont les zones
à faibles émissions de mobilité.
Petit à petit,
les véhicules les plus polluants
ne pourront plus y circuler.
L'objectif : réduire les émissions
de polluants et améliorer
la qualité de l'air.
Chaque année, la pollution
atmosphérique tue 48 000 Français.
11 métropoles ont déjà
mis en place une ZFE,
et toutes les agglomérations
de plus de 150 000 habitants
vont devoir le faire d'ici 2025.
Les habitants de Mézières,
à 55 km de Paris,
dans la circonscription du député,
doivent déjà composer
avec la ZFE parisienne.
Ici, beaucoup s'y rendent
tous les jours en voiture.
Bruno Millienne compte
sur la pédagogie
pour la faire accepter.
-Ca va ?
-Dans ces zones périphériques,
le sujet est sensible.
-Je fais une centaine
de kilomètres tous les jours,
entre ici et là-bas,
les déplacements clientèle.
Je vais de l'autre côté de Paris.
Je suis pleinement concernée.
On en arrive même
à faire un covoiturage.
Je rapatrie tout le monde,
je les prends ici.
On va ensemble travailler.
-Si tu dois changer de véhicule,
tu passerais
à l'électrique ou à l'hybride ?
-Electrique, non.
-Pourquoi ?
-Je suis parfois amenée
à faire des centaines de kilomètres.
Sincèrement, je me vois pas
à l'électrique.
L'électrique pur, je m'y vois pas.
-Habitant, moi, en appartement,
j'ai pas de prise.
Tout ce qui est électrique,
c'est impossible.
Avec nos revenus, on peut pas
aller vers des véhicules neufs.
-Et le jour où vous ne pourrez plus
entrer dans la ZFE ?
-On n'aura pas le choix
que de trouver
une autre alternative.
Si je le dois,
soit je démissionnerai,
soit transports en commun.
-Mes amis, c'est pareil.
On en parle car ils disent :
"On va peut-être devoir démissionner
"parce qu'on ne pourra pas
faire autrement."
-Avec cette mission,
on a eu conscience des freins,
de l'explosion sociale.
Le boulot qu'on a fait,
c'est d'arriver à trouver
à tout le monde
une alternative à la voiture.
-Au niveau des transports,
c'est compliqué.
J'ai pas de bus, pas de train.
Je fais 30 minutes de voiture
avant d'accéder au train,
1h30 à 2 heures de train.
En voiture, pour aller chez moi,
j'ai 80 km.
Je mets 1 heure,
en ayant les bouchons.
-Je comprends bien.
Les transports en commun,
c'est pas la solution.
On a un problème
de transport en commun.
Si demain, on a des locations
à prix relativement bas,
à la fois sur l'électrique...
L'électrique, c'est pas la solution,
mais au moins sur l'hybride.
Est-ce que c'est une solution ?
-Si le loyer est acceptable, oui.
-Tout le monde sait
que le reste à charge est important.
C'est à l'étude
au ministère et ça va se faire vite
pour accélérer le mouvement.
-A Paris, les vignettes Crit'Air
4 et 5 sont déjà interdites.
En 2030, seuls les Crit'Air 1
et les véhicules électriques
pourront circuler.
Il faut donc développer
les alternatives au tout-voiture.
Ici, la solution,
c'est le train et le futur RER,
mais pour cela,
encore faut-il adapter la gare.
-Ce sera essentiel
à partir du moment
où la ZFE à Paris sera contrôlée
et que les gens
auront du mal à voir
comment ils peuvent circuler,
comment ils peuvent
se rendre à Paris
sans prendre leur voiture,
pour ceux qui continuent
à la prendre.
Là, c'est un enjeu important.
-L'échéance, c'est 2024,
quand les premières contraventions
vont tomber.
Le député veut faire de cette gare
d'Epône-Mézières un modèle,
un pôle multimodal qui regroupe
tous les modes de transport.
L'idée, c'est que les automobilistes
laissent ici leur voiture
pour prendre le train,
le RER
ou le bus express pour Paris.
Les élus ont un ambitieux projet.
-Ca va, Franck ?
-Ca va ?
Alors, ce sera des bus
à peu près sur cet endroit-là.
Tu vas avoir un bâtiment
où il y aura du logement.
La brasserie sera
au rez-de-chaussée.
Tout le parking
que t'as là-bas sera réservé
au pôle d'échange multimodal,
avec un parking silo de 650 places.
-D'accord.
-C'est un parking en hauteur.
-A étages.
-A étages, qui va faire
à peu près quatre étages.
-Gratuit ?
-Comme il est conventionné
Ile-de-France Mobilités,
il sera gratuit pour ceux
qui ont le passe Navigo.
-Reste une interrogation :
les transports en commun
seront-ils suffisants
pour tous ces nouveaux voyageurs ?
-Les chiffres qu'Ile-de-France
Mobilités et Eole ont,
d'après eux, ce sera
suffisamment dimensionné.
-Il faut se méfier
d'Ile-de-France Mobilités.
Non, je rigole.
-Je ne suis que maire
de Mézières-sur-Seine.
Chacun a ses responsabilités.
-Comment vous l'appréhendez,
cette montée en puissance
de la ZFE de Paris,
de l'agglomération Grand Paris ?
-Pour l'habitant, mal.
Maintenant, on dit :
"Les amis,
"prenez de l'essence
vignette Crit'Air 1,
"de l'électrique ou de l'hybride."
Pour l'habitant et l'administré,
c'est plus compliqué.
1 euro, c'est 1 euro.
Il va falloir qu'on accompagne,
que l'Etat accompagne réellement...
-L'Etat accompagne déjà, mon ami.
-Oui, mais encore plus.
Ca va être compliqué
pour l'habitant.
-On peut arriver
à trouver une alternative
à chaque citoyen.
Même s'ils y croient pas
aujourd'hui,
je te promets que ça existe.
-Le député en est persuadé.
Reste à convaincre
les automobilistes.
L'autre mission
que s'est donnée le député,
c'est d'accompagner les élus.
Bruno Millienne a entamé
un tour de France
pour les guider
dans la mise en place des ZFE.
Ce jour-là,
escale au Bouscat,
dans l'agglomération de Bordeaux.
Les élus
veulent des conseils
pour leur future ZFE
qui doit voir le jour
d'ici 2025.
Le député les incite
à la concertation.
-Ce qui est arrivé,
c'est que ça partait
dans tous les sens,
que chacun faisait comme il voulait
sur son territoire
sans tenir compte des territoires
limitrophes à la ZFE.
Or, vous le savez
aussi bien que moi,
le problème est pas tant
à l'intérieur des ZFE,
parce qu'en général,
il y a des mobilités
alternatives.
C'est plus pour les gens
qui sont à l'extérieur,
donc au niveau acceptation
sociale et économique
pour les commerçants,
artisans,
ceux qui viennent faire les marchés
à l'intérieur des ZFE.
Faut pas leur dire : "On va
vous aider à changer de véhicule."
C'est : "On vous offre
une alternative à un véhicule."
Il faut qu'on repense
l'usage de la voiture.
-Pour un certain nombre de gens,
ça va être un changement de vie.
Même le reste à charge
de 3000 euros,
pour certaines familles,
c'est inabordable.
Ca se programme
sur plusieurs années.
C'est des choix de familles
qui sont faits
pour pouvoir acheter ça
ou changer de mode de déplacement.
-L'aspect subjectif va être
important dans cette affaire.
Le sentiment
de privation de liberté...
-C'est sûr.
-...ça va être vécu comme ça.
-Le risque de colère,
voire d'explosion sociale,
est dans tous les esprits.
Il y a les particuliers,
mais il y a aussi
les commerçants et les artisans
qui seront directement touchés.
Pour eux aussi,
l'impact financier
n'est pas négligeable.
A Bordeaux, Marc et Camille
tiennent une boutique
de saumon fumé,
et ils ne voient pas comment
ils pourront changer d'utilitaire
quand la ZFE
va se mettre en place.
-Et donc, bonjour.
-Bonjour !
-On va pas tout manger.
-Ah, vous pouvez.
Je suis toute la semaine
en livraison sur Bordeaux,
intra...
-Intra -ZFE, vous, en plus.
-Intra-rocade,
en plein dedans.
Aujourd'hui, on va être obligés
de changer de véhicule,
parce que notre véhicule
est assez ancien.
-On va faire des aides
pour le remplacement
des véhicules utilitaires légers,
ce qui est votre cas.
Ca existe déjà.
On va le faire plus.
Donc il y aura
des solutions de subvention
pour changer de véhicule.
La prime à la conversion,
c'est 7000 euros.
-J'entends bien,
mais ça coûte 30 000 euros,
un véhicule.
-Vous pouvez le faire
sur un véhicule
d'occasion.
-Les véhicules d'occasion
aujourd'hui...
-Si, vous en avez.
Je vous jure.
-Mais il faut quand même
sortir les 20 000 euros.
-Ce n'est pas dans leur budget,
surtout vu la conjoncture.
Alors, le député leur propose
une autre solution.
-Il y a d'autres alternatives
que de passer à l'électrique.
Il y a le rétrofitage
pour passer à l'électrique,
qui coûte moins cher
que d'en prendre un neuf,
et il y a le rétrofitage
pour passer au gaz.
C'est ça ?
-Voilà, c'est là.
-Ben il est bien,
encore, celui-là.
-Le rétrofit,
c'est garder le même véhicule
en changeant seulement le moteur.
-Il faut que les aides
que vous obtenez pour passer
à l'électrique ou autre chose,
en tout cas moins polluant,
faut pas que
ça vous coûte plus cher
que si vous échangez
votre véhicule
contre un véhicule
identique au diesel.
Ce qui est un fatras,
c'est toutes les aides
qui ne sont pas regroupées
sur un site.
On a demandé qu'il y ait
un guichet unique
qui répertorie
collectivité par collectivité
à la fois
les aides de l'Etat,
qui sont communes
à l'ensemble de la France,
et les aides possibles
sur des collectivités
pour que chacun sache
à quoi il a droit.
-Un constructeur automobile
a déjà identifié
ce marché du rétrofit.
A Flins,
dans sa circonscription,
Bruno Millienne vient découvrir
le projet du groupe Renault.
Avec une start-up,
il lance le rétrofit
des véhicules utilitaires.
-Pourquoi ? Parce que
le véhicule utilitaire,
c'est essentiellement du diesel,
donc il va être vite confronté
à des changements du fait
de la mise en place des ZFE.
Le véhicule
est utilisé au quotidien
pour l'activité
de professionnels.
S'ils ont plus leur véhicule,
difficile pour eux de continuer.
C'est aussi des véhicules
qui sont plus chers à l'achat
et qui ont généralement
un équipement spécifique.
Du coup, le rétrofit
a du sens pour eux.
-Sur ce rétrofit
en moteur électrique,
vous tapez dans le mille.
C'est parfait.
-On a pas encore fixé définitivement
le prix du rétrofit,
mais il pourra être redescendu
par une aide nationale.
-Le premier utilitaire rétrofité
sortira en janvier 2024.
Le constructeur
a décidé d'investir
dans les nouvelles mobilités.
-On a créé une marque dédiée,
Mobilize,
pour amener un service
d'autopartage.
On essaye
de proposer des solutions
qui accompagnent
le déploiement des ZFE.
La logique, c'est que ces ZFE
soient pilotées par les territoires,
et en tant qu'industriels,
on aurait besoin d'une carte,
y compris pour notre réseau,
savoir quelles sont les aides
dans tel territoire,
quelles sont
les interdictions...
On est en attente là-dessus
pour pouvoir accompagner
ce déploiement de ZFE.
-Vous l'aviez déjà entendu,
ce besoin des entreprises ?
-Non. Donc c'est bien.
-Vous l'aviez pas identifié ?
-C'est une pierre de plus
à l'édifice.
-Bruno Millienne va poursuivre
son tour de France,
à l'écoute des besoins,
à la recherche de nouvelles idées.
Mais il va surtout devoir
faire preuve de pédagogie
et informer
sur les solutions alternatives.
En 2030,
80 % des voitures
qui circulent aujourd'hui
ne pourront plus rentrer
dans les ZFE.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...